[MUSIC PLAYING]
SPEAKER 1: So my photo is
called Tuesday In London.
I actually took
it-- on Tuesdays,
I had my early modern art class.
And that day we were actually
having class at Tate Modern.
And so the picture I took was
when I was coming out of class
and going back to class
over the Thames River
on the Millennium Bridge.
The fact that you have a
beautiful piece of architecture
just rising up in the
skyline and that contrast
between the old and the new.
So I thought it would give
you a really good idea of what
London is all about.
SPEAKER 2: So we are
staying in the mountains.
And we decide to
do a gaucho ride
and just spend about two hours
riding through the mountains.
And so I was there
with my camera just
snapping away at anything I saw.
And this photo came about
when I let my camera rest
as it was hanging
around my neck.
And as I look through
it, I saw, oh, it's
actually a nice king of
frame within a frame.
And so I snapped and that
is how it came about.
SPEAKER 3: When I was up
there on top of the mountain,
I wanted to try to capture
the entire scene, which
is nearly impossible to do.
So there was an option
on the phone at the time
that you could take
an aerial view.
So you essentially just
captured every scene around you,
above you, and below you
forming a globe-like picture.
It somehow managed to
make the part of Tenerife
that I was at look like
it's own individual world,
little country.
SPEAKER 4: I want to become
a foreign correspondent.
And that's directly because of
having taken journalism classes
here and then
being able to apply
some of the lessons
learned, especially
in terms of the on-the-ground
ethical behaviors
that are necessary.
SPEAKER 5: Through
the global seminar,
through environmental and
scientific filmmaking,
I felt that my experience,
my artistic experience,
and my artistic eye along
with my course work in science
and my interest in
science, I was finally
able to sort of marry these two
disciplines into something that
was incredibly fun and
engaging to work on.
[MUSIC PLAYING]